joining me now for reaction is Scotty
longer a former CIA officer based in
Russia
Stephen Yates a former Deputy Assistant
Vice President Dick Cheney for national
security affairs and here in the studio
Matt slap chairman of the American
Conservative Union Matt your reaction
yeah I think what you said really
captures it which is the most important
part of this is the policy should we be
getting along with Putin's Russia
absolutely the idea that you have
liberals almost calling for open warfare
is absurd at the st. by the same token
it's fair to criticize the president
today he had some errant answers he gave
some answers that are actually uncoupled
from his own tough policy and I think
we'd go back to what's important looking
at the policy I think he's got it dead
on right Scott your time in Russia as a
CIA officer watching Vladimir Putin you
you see he never really left the KGB
behind I mean he he is crafty he's very
canny savvy the way he answers questions
turns them around on on the journalists
and and so forth but what was your big
takeaway from today the media focusing
on Trump's seeming to draw a moral
equivalence between the US Intel
services and Putin's assurances well as
you said Laura Theo the Selective
outrage of the of liberal media is
breathtaking to behold they criticize
President Trump almost as if he was
sending 150 billion dollars on a pallet
to Iran for example but in fact are in
fact our policies directed against
Russia are considerably stronger than
they were a decade ago and it's starting
to tell another key point that perhaps
you missed was that our present energy
policy our energy policy of exporting
increasing our exports of natural gas to
no other in the Europe is in fact
undercutting Russian natural gas and
hurting them where they live its
depriving President Putin of the revenue
he needs for mischief making abroad so
our policies are working and in this
case deeds speak stronger than the
occasional gaffes of the US president
yeah it's got I think if Donald Trump
were up there
and just started lobbing insults at
Putin I think that gives Putin
a real PR victory at home because he can
go home and say look we've gotten so
much under their skin look I stood I
stood up to the president and he doesn't
but you use that for your nationalistic
ends at home
that's absolutely I lived in the Soviet
Union with in the old days in 1983 for a
semester in college and that was when
under Opel was president that was in the
real dark days of the Quickie president
the presidential terms back then but the
idea that he's gonna like just lob
insults at him that is just ridiculous
it's unrealistic we don't do that with
president G Obama didn't and as far as I
can tell neither did Bush we rolled out
the red carpet and China took 50 million
of our personnel files during the Obama
administration I never even heard him
talk about it that's right and another
thing to remember is that we have an
unprecedented incredibly biased press
now I can't imagine right now if there
was at the Reykjavik summit with
President Reagan and Gorbachev having a
Western media that would be asking
Reagan in front of the world's cameras
to denounce the leader of or in this
case Gorbachev as a liar to his face
because this shows that you know the
progressive mainstream media is more
willing to grenade throw in the name of
D railing Trump than it is in supporting
any possible improvement in letting it
Stephen in on the Stephen when when
Ronald Reagan called the Soviet Union an
evil empire the left went crazy
your saber-rattling they called him
Ronnie Reagan when I talked to Craig
Shirley biographer shortly about this
they went nuts they said Reagan was was
it was kicking the hornet's nest in this
so vien we should get along with the
Soviet Union that was during the Cold
War now we're post Cold War we still
have challenges but now they want to get
tough on Russia I just love I mean this
is what I'm howling at this because for
those of us who are around this town and
they in the 80s and if we worked in the
Reagan administration you couldn't get a
break with the left on his dealings with
the Soviet Union but now they want to
set up a shadow government I want to
play something for you Steven for you to
react to this is Philip Mudd former CIA
man under Obama let's watch
FBI director continues the investigation
Department of Justice continued support
for the investigation Congress continues
saying that this investigations
curious point in American government
when do we see almost a shadow
government come out and say we cannot
side with the government whether it's
the cabinet or the Senate I think that's
the big question
Stephen shadow government needs to form
to apparently undo the presidential
election your reaction well where's a
former Obama CIA director calling
treason when you need him because that's
actually what that would be and I think
you know we've really really run the
limits on absolute trump derangement
syndrome across the board on how people
react to this kind of thing but really I
think the president was trying to do two
hard things at one time today and that
might have been what's tripped up some
of the communications I agree completely
on the strategy side of it that you got
in the angle he's restoring realism
trying to get great power relations back
on track balancing one power against
another to try to solve real problems
the proof of this is in results not an
instantaneous sound bites but he's also
the deal maker he wants something now
and he's jumping in there and I think
the deal maker in him used some traits
there in the presser that complicated
what I think he's actually doing very
well
on the longer term strategy fascinating
Matt this is what the media were saying
today about what the Intel Chiefs should
be doing here in the United States and
reaction to what we saw in Helsinki
let's watch president Trump basically
said he believes Vladimir Putin over his
intelligence community should the
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates resigned in protest I think the
right thing for dan coates to do would
be to send a clear message and say he
can no longer serve this president how
does Gina Haskell stay on the job how
does Dan Coates stay on the table
he has now rebuked their professional
assessment of Russia's role in meddling
in the 2016 election everyone's got to
resign apparently because because I've
had that president Trump is doing what
the previous administrations tried to do
remember the reset button
remember your clip about Medvedev saying
let's wait till after they went like
this Matt it was like this can you
imagine if Trump like held Baldomir
Putin's and today I mean this is what I
will translate that
demon later thank you very much what
some other presidents tried to start the
relationship off on the right foot
they're called you know warriors for
peace Donald Trump tries to do that and
he's called deranged and people should
look I agree with you he had some
answers that were off the mark but the
policy is right and the president needs
to understand he's winning on this stick
to the course he's winning on it and I
think I think this is there are two
things you can hold in your mind at the
same time number one having a better
relationship with Russia
I heard Bill Richardson say that on TV
today we had Obama say it Hillary say it
Bush said it we drove around his pickup
truck with Vladimir Putin Reno Crawford
he looked into his heart everything he
saw his soul but so Steven I think you
could have those two thoughts in your
mind better relationship with Russia and
also have a clear-eyed view of what
Russia's complex history they're very
proud people they love the motherland
still at the glory days they think they
don't want him to be behind them but
their economy has shrunk their
population is shrinking they're in many
ways on the decline and they're not the
threat that China is to us I mean their
economy what is it half the size of
California I mean it's ridiculous your
US economy Dwarfs that of Russia at this
point and that's what made it even more
laughable when we're having a discussion
about NATO and where the European
countries should pay their fair share
and I think you know if Nixon can go to
China during the great proletarian
Cultural Revolution when literally
dozens and dozens of millions of Chinese
people are killed by their own sixty
million and and we can talk about
geopolitics and real things that they
need to change in the world
because even more lives are at stake if
we don't that's what's going on when
you're talking about the nuclear
stockpile it's not just whether and
Russia uses it it's whether Russia sells
it and proliferate sit and so that's the
stakes all right fascinating panel thank
you all great perspectives